Joining me today is the founding editor
of clearly,
man,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks Dave.
Thanks for having me.
I am thrilled to finally have you here.
This has been like,
what,
87 years in the making.
Well,
I live a very long way away so it's
difficult for me to get here.
Yeah,
well you made it.
You made it thousands of miles.
You are part of what I would say is idw
Australia,
I suppose.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
okay,
so there's a ton I want to talk to you
about it.
Obviously I want to focus on Colette and
the work that you're doing and we
obviously have a lot in common on the
issues that we care about and things of
that nature,
but first off you are from Australia.
I've only had I think a two other guests
that are Australian natives on the show.
What's going on in Australia these days?
What,
what is the rest of the world needed to
know about Australia?
I would say that in Australia we're
pretty chilled out at the moment,
at least politically and culturally
compared to America and even your,
to a large extent,
we have a,
we've had,
um,
25 years or more of economic growth,
so people are pretty relaxed.
People are doing well,
the middle class is doing well.
Um,
there's not so much of a feeling that
there's a zero sum competition going on,
like people are fighting over scarce
resources and you know,
we obviously have political correctness
and identity politics and a lot of
that's being imported from America.
Yeah.
How does that get important?
Because I was mentioning to you right
before we started that a
disproportionate amount of our patrons,
the people who support this show more
Australia.
So even if things are going pretty well,
there's definitely a segment of people
that are going,
something's either not right or where
we're seeing the science be coming.
Yeah,
it's true.
I mean it's difficult to identify
exactly how these cultural trends get
imported.
But um,
for example,
through universities,
through social media,
through traditional medium,
so similar narratives get picked up by
journalists like the oppression,
narratives and um,
and we're seeing with the,
with the young,
younger generations how the,
how they pick up ideology through social
media and through the echo chambers and
the filter bubbles that are so easily
accessible.
Yeah.
Do you think that there is a geographic
reason that some of this stuff hasn't
fully hit Australia yet?
I mean,
being surrounded by water and pretty
from the rest of us,
there's probably a little bit of safety
in that I would imagine.
Although borders are changing just
because of technology.
Yeah.
It's um,
yeah.
So we're more isolated,
that's for sure.
With smaller.
Um,
so we don't have the same.
We're not as diverse as other places
like Europe and the United States.
We have less income inequality in
Australia which makes a.
and um,
we're,
we're actually kind of parochial as
well.
I mean we do pick up cultural trends
from America,
but at the same time we just focus on
cooking shows and reality TV and
football games.
Yeah.
So when the article came out back in,
was it may or so the renegades of the
intellectual dark web,
you were included in there and many of
us had not even met you.
This is actually our first time meeting
in person even though we've been
chatting online for awhile.
Were you shocked about the reaction to
that article because it really did sort
of level up all of the issues that we've
been all talking about?
No,
I wasn't shocked at all.
I think that the general movement,
this ideas movement,
any pushback of the sort of moral
orthodoxy that the politically correct
left have at the moment.
It's been brewing for some time and
someone just had to put a label on it.
Someone just had to name it.
And um,
I wasn't shocked by the groundswell of
reaction to it because I've been seeing
it through my work with.
There are just so many people who writes
me every day who say,
I love what you're doing.
I can't write a blog myself.
I can't put my name on it because I
would get in trouble at work or in my
university where there are so many
people who,
um,
want to participate in these discussions
but can't for whatever reason and um,
you know,
they like to be now be able to put a
label on this general movement.
Yeah.
So tell me a little bit about your
personal background.
What led you to be one of the people
that is okay,
putting your name on this stuff because
I do think that's one of the huge issues
here.
We get all this support from academics,
people in politics and regular folks who
were like,
and I see the dangers,
but I don't want to put my name on it.
So how did Claire Lehman ended up here?
Willing to put your name and face to all
this stuff?
You know,
I,
I think I have a bit more of a risk
taking streak in my nature and I don't
feel the same fear around social
disapproval as a lot of other people.
Um,
so I was a psychology graduate student
and I left my Grad program and before I
left I sort of,
um,
uh,
took a few risks during,
during my program and,
and was sort of hung out to dry by the
university,
so to speak.
An example of one of those sort of lit
up when you said it.
Well,
I,
I complained about the amount of unpaid
work that psychology students had to do
in a clinic that was associated with the
university and they weren't happy with
that and I sort of received a bit
retaliation for sort of almost whistle
blowing on the amount of exploitation
this clinic was involved in.
So I've always said the first time I
took a risk,
um,
I've always taken risks when I've felt
that my conscience demands that I do so.
And what led me to create Colette was,
um,
when I was a graduate student,
I was involved in a lot of online
discussions with academics in psychology
and we had such fascinating,
interesting discussions that were
completely unlike anything that you
would see in mainstream media.
And I thought,
firstly,
there's a business opportunity here.
If I can bring some of these
conversations to a market,
and secondly,
you know,
people need to know that there are,
there is scientific evidence in some of
these topics and mainstream journalists
and neglecting to,
um,
inform readers about some of these
issues or some of,
some of this evidence.
Yeah.
So I want to read the mission statement
from Colette because it's pretty
freaking perfect.
Colette is a platform for free thought.
We respect ideas,
even dangerous ones.
We also believe that free expression and
the free exchange of ideas help human
societies flourish and progress.
Quill that aims to provide a platform
for this exchange.
Everybody seems to be afraid of
dangerous ideas right now.
Right?
I mean,
that's why this little crew of people
are together for whatever our
differences are.
Yeah.
I think that there's a,
there's been a conflation between giving
a platform or exploring ideas and
endorsing ideas and they're not the same
thing.
So I will publish stuff on collect that
I don't necessarily agree with
politically.
Um,
I don't see the fact of publishing and
in a,
necessarily as an endorsement,
I also am very clear that I'm going to
make mistakes as an editor.
I'm a,
we don't want to make mistakes about
accuracy and if we're ever called out
for publishing something that's not
factually correct,
we will own up to that mistake,
but you know,
we're living in a time of intense
ideological flux and to work out where
we're all going,
we need to be able to talk about things
freely and we need to be able to make
mistakes and I think make,
being able to make mistakes is a sign of
a healthy environment and it's a sign
of,
you know,
it's part of the creative process.
Um,
so the,
the,
the worry is who want to shut down,
debate,
who want to shut down free speech and
um,
give you that.
Giving a platform for exploring
dangerous ideas is equivalent to
endorsing them.
They're basically that you can't make a
mistake.
And that's,
that's really scary because the only way
we move forward is to experiment,
test new ideas,
see,
see what works and pick the best ones
out of the,
the experimentation process and move
forward that way.
Yeah.
So I want to discuss some of the
dangerous ideas.
Sure.
That your platform.
But it's interesting that you said this
thing about you don't mind making
mistakes because I feel very much the
same.
I will sit down with all sorts of
people.
I've done it before.
People I agree with and disagree with
some people who I really don't like what
they're talking about,
but I try to give everybody a fair
shake.
And what I'm noticing is there's a
tremendous amount of pushback just on
that.
That's what you're getting to.
Like the idea that hey,
you can sit down with someone and
separate a human being from their ideas,
but also that there's this sort of
secondary thing that I'm noticing and I
think you,
you get it too just from the articles
you guys put out,
which is that if I don't ask the exact
question that someone wants me to ask or
I miss this or I word this this way,
but just this,
this army that doesn't feel that organic
to me is ready to pounce and I'm really
trying to work through that.
Like I don't spend too much time
thinking about it,
but it is a conscious thing like,
oh,
there's going to be this group of people
that no matter what I do and really what
they're trying to do is chill everybody
out so that you'll only talk about what
they're comfortable with.
Yeah.
Well,
there,
there are people at the moment who feel
that all the important questions have
been answered.
All of the important moral and ethical
dilemmas have an answer and that at this
point in history,
everything's been worked out and anyone
who's I'm exploring different ideas or
is doubtful about these moral issues is
evil.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Um,
so I come,
I come from a different approach where
like,
I don't know it's going on,
like I'm trying to work it out with
other people and um,
I want the freedom to be able to explore
in a weird way.
Does that get you the most hate?
Because I think I really believe that's
where most people are.
I think that's why people appreciate
what I do here.
I'm just being open about my journey and
listening to people and learning all of
that and that.
But that opens you up from hate from the
both sides.
It's a lot easier to just stake out a
position and then you'll only get hate
one way,
but when you're like,
I am going to hear both sides,
you know,
it's why I love listening to Sam Harris
and Jordan Peterson debate,
you know,
the biggest existential questions that
there are.
It's like,
it's like,
if I've completely settled my mind on
this,
I don't know,
I wouldn't be that impressed with my
thought process or something.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I don't get a lot of hate.
I certainly have twitter trolls,
but
way too,
we,
um,
I sort of don't really notice it.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's probably the most simple way to
deal with this.
All right.
So let's,
let's talk about some of those dangerous
ideas.
What are some dangerous ideas that have
bubbled up from your writers that you've
had to think about or that you're
focused on these days?
Yeah,
so because my background is in
psychology,
um,
we tackle issues that come from the
behavioral sciences.
So we've looked at sex differences,
psychological sex differences between
men and women,
differences in interests in occupations.
Um,
so we've published some articles on why
there are fewer women in computer
science,
for example.
And um,
we published a analysis of Jameson was
google memo written by four different
scientists who have some expertise in
that area.
Uh,
we've published on intelligence reports.
What were some of the results?
Yeah,
well they,
you know,
they basically said that something
pretty similar that he was in the
ballpark in terms of getting the science
right and he's position is valid in
terms of regular scientific debate.
There are observable sex differences
between men and women.
The differences in interest in
occupations is very robust and reliable,
so women are overwhelmingly interested
in occupations which have something to
do with people,
so caring professions,
medicine,
even law whereas men have more interest
in occupations that are to do with
systems and things,
so anything mechanical,
computer science and there's no,
there's no difference between the
average intelligent school is between
men and women and the evidence around
differences in verbal and mathematical
ability is somewhat mixed.
The mean you can,
you can have debates backwards and
forwards over the strengths of those
differences,
but the difference in interest is very
robust.
Why are people so afraid of that?
Why is it that there is a set of people
out there right now that want us to add
to be all equal in their minds,
but it would actually force us to go
against nature.
I mean that's what.
That's what this really is.
Well,
there is a fear that if you acknowledge
that there are differences between
individuals or groups,
that you're saying that one group is
inferior,
so there's been a,
they,
the idea that we have to be the same to
be equal has been a very prevalent and
strong idea.
I don't know who came where the idea
comes from,
but it's,
it's,
um,
it's dangerous because if,
if you argue that no true equality can
be achieved,
unless we're all the same,
then no,
then we can't have a quality.
However,
if you argue that no,
we are all morally equal and that we
deserve equal opportunity and uh,
the equal,
um,
uh,
we,
we deserve equal opportunities to live a
happy,
flourishing life.
However,
there are differences between us.
Then you can preserve that ethical
principle.
So it's very problematic for people who
think that there can be no equality
between men and women unless we're
proven to be the same identical because
the evidence doesn't support the idea
that we're the same.
What are,
what are some of the other dangerous
ideas?
Okay.
So we've
the dangerous role.
Yeah.
Um,
we've published work on intelligence
research,
which is controversial.
Uh,
we've published articles about the
heritage.
Are you talking about intelligence and
race?
Okay.
This seems to be one of their people
seem to be all
that's.
Yeah,
that's a hugely controversial issue.
And uh,
we've published,
um,
we published a defense of the child's
marries the bell curve because after he
had his conversation with Sam Harris,
vox came out and wrote a hit piece or
right at some,
some kind of article that misrepresented
what they talked about and the bell
curve.
And so we published a response from
Professor Richard Hire who's the editor
of the intelligence journal,
so he's a preeminent expert in this
area.
And he defended Charles Murray's book
and defended the conversation that they
had and said this is an important issue.
It's scientifically valid and has merit
to talk about these issues.
And they got,
they were,
they got the science right.
Um,
so we,
we don't aim to be provocative for the
sake of just being inflammatory,
right?
We,
we have an objective where we want to
protect the scientists who are having,
who are doing this work or who are
having these conversations we want us,
we want to protect the individuals who
are doing the knowledge production or
the research we want to protect them
from the boxes and the journalists who
just want to write hate pieces just to
get the clicks so we have a sort of a
commitment to those people who are doing
risky work and need that kind of
protection.
You're going to my soft spot today
because as,
as we're taking this as we're taping
this only like an hour ago,
vox did a piece about me about how I'm
part of the reactionary right?
And it's just like you guys are awful.
So when a weird way your,
your,
your job in some respects has become
sort of like a force field to just allow
people to do the work that they're
supposed to be doing.
Yeah.
Because.
Right?
Because universities for all sorts of
different reasons,
uh,
neglecting their duty to academic
freedom and academic freedom is meant to
exist to protect scientists in
particular who are doing work,
which contradicts the religious
orthodoxy of the time or the moral
orthodoxy.
And it's quite clear to me that there
are scientists doing work which
challenges politically correct dogmas
and I don't see universities doing a
very good job at protecting those
scientists.
And so we feel like we can fill the gap.
Where,
where do you think the gender studies
stuff fits into all this?
Because in a weird way it seems like
it's all being whittled down to that
somehow that now,
especially related to trans issues,
I was just talking to a fairly well
known public professor yesterday off the
record about how he's going into his
old,
even though he's factually correct and
it's calm,
you know,
confident about his research.
He's going into old lesson plans to
change wording just because he doesn't
want to deal with the mob.
So things that were completely
acceptable three,
four years ago is now having to edit
out.
I mean,
that's,
that's truly dangerous.
So what is going on with the gender
studies department and the rest of this
moving so fast,
it's hard to really,
um,
to analyze what's going on when it's
shifting so fast.
But certainly many of the humanities
departments took a turn back in the 19
seventies and they took,
they,
um,
took on these fashionable theories such
as poststructuralism and uh,
they,
they rejected empirical methods.
Um,
and so then the argument,
if we were trying to give them the
credit that they're due,
at least in the argument,
if you're,
if you're rejecting empirical science or
verbal facts,
what is your argument that leads you
there?
Because I know people are watching us
go,
that's just sounds crazy,
but they obviously believe it.
So let's try to give the devil his deal,
right?
Yeah.
So
postmodernist have a good point and that
is that we are all biased and a
scientist looking at an issue such as,
um,
sexuality has his or her own biases.
Right?
And so the questions that the scientists
asks when he or her,
he or she is designing a survey or
designing a lab experiment,
I'm going to have some bias embedded
within them.
So that's true.
And the postmodernist had that insight.
However,
the mistake they make is getting rid of
an empirical and objective methods all
together and just saying because we're
biased,
what's the point?
Right?
So they're doing like a massive
overcorrection
yes,
yes.
When,
when,
what should be done is acknowledging,
yes,
we all have our bias.
Um,
and if I'm a scientist designing a
study,
I'm going to have my bias and it might
get embedded into the work that I'm
doing.
However,
there are ways to correct that and we
want to improve our quantitative
methodologies in order to correct for
our own biases.
So the problem that the postmodernist
have is that they say,
well,
the bias is there,
so let's put it all in the bin and we're
just going to double down on the bias
and just talk about lived experience.
I mean,
that is just taking the completely the
wrong direction,
right?
I mean,
it's quite literally the reverse of the
scientific method,
so basically they're saying that that
bias is truth,
right?
I mean if you're saying bias that the
lived experience is what truth is,
then bias is true.
You know,
I don't know if you saw it,
but I did this,
this talk at University of New Hampshire
and this woman was yelling at me,
this trans woman calling me all right,
and all of this other nonsense shouting
me down.
I didn't realize this till two months
later or something,
but it turned out she was a gender
studies professor at the school.
So you've got a gender studies professor
trying to shout down and invited speaker
while live tweeting that I'm alright or
whatever,
and it's like,
I'm pretty sure maybe I'm not right
about everything.
I'll concede on that.
Even though I wanted it.
I said she should be treated with
respect and equality and all that,
but your bias that you're acting on
right now,
it definitely is not closer to truth
than what I was saying.
Yeah.
So I.
The way I think of it is that,
you know,
there is an objective reality and the
way we get to objective realities
through the scientific method,
um,
whereas post modernists,
academics believe a lot of them believe
that reality is created through language
and discourse and I think that's one of
the reasons why they believe that words
can be violence because if reality is
actually created three language and
discourse and there's some kind of,
there's some toxic discourse,
then they truly believed that reality
can be changed through words.
And so I think that's why they get so
upset about freedom of speech and just
having discussions because they truly
believe that words can change the way
the world is constructed.
Right?
So for now they say it's okay to punch a
Nazi.
Well,
they call everybody Nazis.
Then it's okay to punch a Nazi and then
we can go however far down that road we
want to go.
And then then you're completely
condoning mines.
How concerned are you that these ideas
are going to trickle up higher into
places of power and that once they look,
we know they're in the media.
You've already mentioned box and a
couple of those other,
but that once they're really into places
of power in Australia,
in the states or wherever else that the
screws are really going to be turned
against us because we're fighting for
free speech would mostly be concerned
about these ideas getting into the law.
Traditionally,
the lore is a conservative field and
they are pretty good at resisting
political fads,
but you can see with the way that law is
taught in law schools at the moment that
there is critical legal studies and
often critical legal studies is a
mandatory component.
So they teach like the feminist
interpretation of law and these
approaches,
um,
can undermine some of the basic
fundamentals of foundations of how the
Lord is meant to work.
So I,
yeah,
I am worried that there are a lot of
attacks on due process at the moment,
freedom of speech and the scientific
method.
Those three things are foundations of a
civilized society and all of them are
being attacked at the moment.
How does me to fit into this?
Because you've been somewhat critical of
that.
I think it's all three of those criteria
that you just laid out there.
Look,
you know,
obviously me to started as a really
legitimate and powerful movement in
identifying the,
the predation that Harvey Weinstein was
engaged in.
And,
and surely there are,
there have been many powerful men,
um,
in the last couple of decades working in
industries where there's a lot of young
women around and they have positions of
power and they're able to exploit those
positions.
But,
you know,
I'm a young woman myself,
right?
And I,
I don't see sexual harassment,
um,
as being,
as pervasive as a lot of people claim.
And I also think it's very dangerous to
make accusations against people publicly
because our reputations are so valuable
and so important that,
um,
you know,
we,
we need to respect other people's
ability to have,
have their,
their reputation and I'm making
accusations in public,
sort of goes against my,
um,
my feeling that it feels indicative to
me and it feels dangerous,
dangerous path to go down because for
every true accusation,
they ease of sexual harassment and is
going to be someone who is,
um,
you know,
there's,
there are going to be people who have
conflicts and then the conflict,
someone feels like they can resolve a
conflict through making an accusation of
sexual harassment.
And that's really scary.
We don't,
we don't want people to resolve their
conflicts by making public accusations.
Right?
But I definitely think there's a certain
set of people that don't mind collateral
damage,
right?
I mean,
that seems to be what's happening right
now.
And people,
you see this public,
people that are tweeting these kinds of
things,
like it doesn't matter if you can take
down a couple of innocent people.
That's how dangerous this thing is.
That strikes me as far more dangerous
and I'm not belittling any of the actual
things that some of these women have
gone through.
Yeah,
it's scary.
It's the desire for collective
punishment and that collective
punishment is is is scary it.
If you look at the Geneva Convention
that was established after World War
Two,
the UN declared collective punishment,
a war crime,
so the idea is that when there is a
conflict between ethnic groups in
certain places,
if if one,
if some people are killed in that inner
conflict,
you can't then go and wipe out a village
as a collective collective rich
retribution because that's how these war
crimes happen.
So now we're this.
I'm like you said,
this collateral damage,
this desire for collateral damage is
being normalized.
Like people don't seem to understand how
dangerous this is and how unjust it is.
What is part of the issue that perhaps
they do understand it,
but they so want to destroy the system.
I've been on tour with Jordan Peterson.
One of the things he's been talking
about a lot lately is yes,
you can acknowledge that we don't have
perfect systems and then there's perfect
systems are probably impossible to ever
get to,
but now we have this new thing in the
system,
which is let's just freaking destroy the
whole thing to build our perfect system.
Yeah.
I think people don't understand because
we're not taught anymore.
We're not taught history properly.
We're not,
we don't learn about human nature in
school and how it's almost an instinct
to want to desire retribution,
retribution,
and vindictive justice.
I think it's,
it's part of our nature is to want to
punish people and punish groups.
Um,
and now institutions like a g process
and the presumption of innocence,
they sort of go against our instincts,
but that's why they say,
yeah.
Yeah.
And I think what we're seeing is just
sort of like a regression back to our
more tribal,
instinctive nature.
And because our education system is so
atrophied,
young people aren't being taught the
value and the fragility of these
institutions,
how they came about,
why they're so important,
why we must protect them.
So I think there's just a basic
ignorance about why these institutions,
institutions exist in the first place
and then we're regressing to our more
primitive natures.
Yeah.
How do you think social media fits into
this?
Because I did a video,
I think it's almost three years ago now,
that online culture is becoming
mainstream culture and I think that
that's what we're seeing there.
What used to be just relegated to the
meme makers and peppy people has now
just leaked everywhere and just everyone
in public is acting sort of as their
worst selves over time that feeds all of
this.
Let's either destroy the system or let's
ignore legitimate problems.
Well,
when you don't have proper law and
order,
you do get more justice in vigilante
justice in real life.
And you can see that throughout history
you've got,
you get lynchings.
Um,
you get pogroms,
you get groups like mobs of people going
and attacking an individual who they
think is guilty of like a sex crime or
some other crime and killing the person.
So,
and then what happened was,
is we developed legal and social norms
that stopped,
that kind of vigilante justice from
taking place and if you are a vigilante
you can,
you can get in trouble with the law and
then we've developed social norms that
prevent people from just forming mobs
and going attacking people in the
street.
But social media is this new technology
and we haven't developed any of the
legal or social norms yet and so it's
brought back this mobbing behavior,
which is part of our nature.
It's brought it back.
But we haven't yet developed any of the
norms to sort of suppress it or mitigate
against it and I think we eventually
will develop these norms but it's gonna
take awhile and there's going to be a
feat.
Innocent people sort of metaphorically
lynched in the process.
Yeah.
So that's actually an interesting segue
to something that's been on my mind
lately.
So you know,
Alex Jones got booted from twitter and
Youtube and facebook or whatever.
I don't even want to talk about any of
the things that he talks about.
It does not matter,
but.
But these tech companies basically
decided that this one guy is too
dangerous,
you know,
Erica and can be on here and Hamas,
whoever you,
whoever else you want to pick that you
don't like can be on your.
But this guy,
you know,
even paypal took them out last week.
Um,
do you think that the free speech crew
for getting his ideas,
do you think we should have offered a
better defense of why this person,
a person should be allowed to use these
things?
I mean,
should guy be allowed to make a phone
call?
Should he allow,
should he be allowed to have running
water at his house?
Where do we draw the lines for days?
Yeah.
Well I think these tools that we use
such as payment processing and social
media such as twitter,
the instant messaging,
their tools and they should be treated
as,
as such,
like having electricity or water.
And um,
so you believe there are public good,
basically the same work,
getting water to your house,
getting the phone line connected to your
house.
Yeah.
And,
and they shouldn't be politicized.
And as soon as you politicize these
tools,
then it's,
there's a slippery slope and you know,
then there's going to be arguments about
who do we band next,
what standards do we want to sit in,
that kind of thing.
In the context of Alex Jones,
I,
I think there's probably more to the
story that the public is aware of.
So I don't want to comment on him
specifically,
but.
And I don't want to make it a bit.
Yeah,
it's just the general idea that a
digital assassination can occur because
we're all agreeing to terms of services
that I'm not sitting around with a
lawyer every time I click accept to the
new service and that eventually you
could move on.
Anybody,
you know what I mean?
We know the way these ideas work.
You don't get one person and then
suddenly be like,
oh,
well we're good to go.
It's like,
who do you get net?
Yeah.
And the,
the payment and processing is,
is scary.
I mean the idea that that should be
politicized is just.
That is crazy.
Yeah.
So what do you think the solution is?
I mean,
I think you probably know what my
solution is that we need more
competition,
but I'm really understanding of big
counter to that because it's like,
where is the county?
Where is it?
Yeah,
no,
look,
I didn't have the onset and I tend
towards being um,
economically liberal.
However,
some of these tools,
as you said,
are public goods and perhaps need to be
thought of as public goods rather than
rather than private.
And um,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm open to ideas of regulation,
government intervention,
and um,
I'm also open to ideas about breaking up
some of the monopolies because we
competition would be lovely,
but it's a bit difficult at the moment
because some of these companies have
gotten monopolies in lots of different
verticals.
So Google,
for example,
has the search engine monopoly they've
got that almost got the advertising
monopoly,
so they're leveraging their monopoly in
one area into others.
And that,
that just shuts down competition.
Yeah.
Do you think it's even something a
little more perverse than that,
which is that,
you know,
look,
there's obviously I'm not blowing the
lid on anything here.
There's obviously tons of discussions
with all sorts of people about how do we
compete with youtube or how do we
compete with any of these things,
but I think partly what's happening,
it's not just people are going there,
this,
this big monolith.
I think people are actually genuinely
afraid of what it means to go up against
them.
It's not like it's going to just be a
hard work situation.
It's like what does it actually mean to
go up against the world's information
leader
can compete against the monopoly.
That's the definition of a monopoly.
That's no competition and these.
Some of these companies,
I'm not police and they have captured
the market so effectively that you
cannot compete with them and so we
either have to think about regulating
them so that they're free and open to
everybody or I'm breaking up their
ability to control the market.
I mean,
yeah,
this is the tough part for the
Libertarian party.
He's like,
no,
not yet.
I do send some being pinned into that.
That kind of answer.
All right,
so we've been talking a bit about the
tech component of this grand cultural
war.
That's going on you guys cool that
you're.
You're a small company or you're funded
on Patrion which were funded on Pedro
and it's pretty awesome.
You have people that voluntarily pay you
to support your content and make you
grow.
I know how validating and rewarding it
is and all that stuff,
but you find yourself often up against
the big boys,
right?
Like box funded to hundreds of millions
of dollars by different things and
you're being critical of them here.
So it does get me to back to something
that I started with before about where
does it come from for you to just be
brave.
I don't want to.
I don't want to belittle that part of it
that there's a new internet developing
and I think is people that are doing
this sort of thing.
It's not these well funded,
well oiled machines that we're watching
them crumble.
You know,
you sent me this morning,
this thing about boxes ad rev is off by
15 percent or something and it's like
we've got slim trim companies and I
think I really believe that's the future
economically of this as well as in terms
of protecting the ideas.
Yeah.
So we,
uh,
a pretty.
We have a pretty amazing story.
Um,
we,
I started by myself and I ran the
website for maybe a year or even a year
and a half before I got my assistant
editor onboard who's now sort of the
managing editor and he's extraordinarily
talented,
extremely hardworking.
So I'm very indebted to him for all
Jonathan,
Jonathan Kay,
um,
and my other editor,
Jamie,
Jamie Palmer,
let's give credit where credit's due.
Um,
am I contribute is also amazing,
but we,
I hate now as of 20,
uh,
2018 September,
we're getting up to 1 million unique
visitors a month with the staff of old
part time staff of six or the six or
seven people.
And we're getting almost a million
uniques a month.
I am aware of magazines that have a
budget of millions of dollars that can
not compete with our traffic and who
have staffs of stop,
like staffing capacity of 30,
40,
50 people.
So we're extremely lane,
but we're hardworking,
uh,
and we're nimble and innovative.
Like I'm very,
I'm always thinking about innovations to
the business model.
What can we do that's different?
I think just following in the footsteps
of the old model is probably a recipe
for failure and I truly believe that
advertising is on the way out.
I know people can still make some money
through advertising,
but I think out of it advertising gives
you a vulnerability because now you see
these activists trying to like target
brands if the brand is next to some
content that activists don't like.
So I think advertising is just,
I think it's bone this vulnerability
associated with it.
And
is it almost a fake vulnerability
though?
Because I always think when,
you know,
they always try to boycott Hannity for
example,
and it's like all of the people trying
to boycott him,
putting aside whatever he said on that
given instance,
they don't watch him in the first place
and yet the advertisers still feel that
they have to bow to the mob.
And I always find that to be a strange
thing.
Like there's very few people who like
Hannity,
who are,
who are so shocked by something he said
that they want to boycott him.
It's always people who hate him in the
first place that don't watch.
So there's an odd piece of this that's
like slightly disconnected from reality.
I think.
Well,
see corporations and companies in
general are skittish and conservative
and they want to protect their
reputations and they,
they're afraid of any kind of
controversy.
And I agree with you that these
activists on social media who are
targeting companies,
they're a tiny,
tiny minority of the population.
Most people don't care or buy into this
stuff,
but corporations is,
it's probably some pr person who's like,
Whoa,
we don't want any controversy.
Let's detach ourselves.
Um,
but you know,
that kind of timidity and lack of
strength and lack of spine is not
something that is part of that.
So we very much a conscious of if we
ever get mobbed and we do get mobbed,
sometimes we don't apologize.
We don't,
we don't,
we don't give into the heckler's veto
basically.
Yeah,
I know.
I,
I really think it's important for um,
uh,
corporations,
company lead is anyone in a latest
leadership position to grow a spine in
the era of social media and to not take
any of this outrage seriously.
Yeah.
Not Take it seriously or not take it.
I mean,
I think we've sort of,
we have to take it seriously because it
is sort of infecting a lot of society,
but maybe not take it as if it's
necessarily right,
just because it's outrageous.
Is that fair?
Yeah.
I,
you can say the recent example,
an editor of the New York review of
books in Borama was fired because he
published an article a by Canadian radio
journalists who was credibly accused of
many cases of sexual assault.
And I think the radio journalists was
like,
he's a bad dude,
but the editor was sacked for publishing
his article within the space of two days
or something.
So there was a social media outrage
phenomenon and it's all wrapped up with
me too.
And then he's just fired just like that.
And it's like,
okay,
take some time out to consider it.
Like,
listen to the feedback from your readers
or from people on social media.
But when did we start making decisions?
So suddenly these important decisions
that affect people's livelihoods,
that's what I find astonishing that
people in leadership positions just sort
of throw all caution to the wind and
just say,
okay,
we're going to sap someone because some
people on twitter on happy.
Yeah.
And also the guilt by association part
of this,
right?
I mean it's,
it's possible for a slim trim operation
that you have,
you might find out in 10 years,
you might find out that one of the guys
you're working with now,
three years ago did did something awful.
And then they'll use that to try to tar
you and the danger of that or that you
sat down with somebody and now we can
put out a chart that links that person
did this person to that person.
This one,
we're in an age of the Internet within
six steps.
You can link anybody to Kevin Bacon or
Barack Obama.
Right?
It's like,
it's,
it's pretty ridiculous.
Yeah.
The guilt by association is it for.
I mean,
it's a fallacy,
but it is powerful and we,
we do find ourselves tainted and it's
tricky and I think we have to.
Every situation we have to judge on a
case by case basis.
Um,
and,
and you probably right,
it probably is going to happen,
but I trust my readers and um,
I,
I feel like they know who we are.
They know they're aware of our values
and they can make the appropriate
judgments at the time.
Yeah.
So.
All right.
So even though we've spent most of the
time here and most of the things that
you guys are writing,
talking about what sort of going on with
the modern left and frustrations that
everyone knows that I have with these
guys.
Um,
let's talk about the parts of their
right,
that,
that you actually find a scary or
untoward or whatever you want to call
it.
What do you think the alt right is at
this point?
Like if someone says you give me the
definition of,
all right,
what does that even mean to you at this
point?
Uh,
well,
I consider them to be the white
nationalists that uh,
um,
that one in ethno state and they,
they're pretty morally repugnant and
that's pretty scary.
And they engage in some,
in quite vicious trolling.
They send death threats.
I'm the journalist.
Cathy Young,
for example,
was one of the first people to write an
article criticizing the bigotry of the
alt right and she had a death threat
called into her home.
And uh,
the,
the pretty scary.
But I think there are a small group.
Yeah.
How are we able to quantify that?
Because that's one of the things that
like I think people are just very
confused that they're making it seem.
The media makes it seem because they
call everyone all right or far right,
that there's this massive group.
I can only talk about this in an
American Lens,
but maybe maybe it's a little different
Australia,
but that there's this massive group of
white nationalists who are coming for to
turn America into some sort of ethno
state.
Now I'm not saying there aren't racists.
Of course they are racist and of course
there are bad people and people using
these tactics,
but I believe it's just a tiny sliver
and then.
And then on top of that you have old
sort of the meme makers and the shit
posters and the rest of those guys.
You may not like what they do,
but they're not there.
They're having fun in their eyes and a
lot of ways they're not just the evil
racist.
I think a mistake was made back when
Milo was around and I think he.
He started using the term alt right and
he might not have been aware of where
that term originated and it actually
originated with the white nationalists
and um,
do you think Milo was using it more in
the way that I just laid it out or just
sort of these shit posting something
without acknowledging the other person.
I don't know if he was aware of where
the term originated or not,
but it was a huge era,
an era for people who are adjusting to
shit posting.
It was a huge era era for them to use
that label for themselves because unless
you're,
what in my view,
unless you are a white nationalist,
you are not an,
you're not an old writer.
I mean they had,
they,
the label I think came about in 2007 and
I think it was Richard Spencer who
created the right journal or something.
So it was a big mistake for people who
just want to have fun online and he
wants to,
um,
you know,
just like push back against some of
these pc orthodoxies.
That was a huge mistake for them to use
the term for themselves and that's given
license now for critics to apply the
term on everybody who,
who pushes back against pc dogmas.
Um,
and that's really unfortunate,
but you know,
we have to just say it over and over
again,
like these people are repugnant and we,
we don't want to have anything to do
with their ideology.
The ideology is all ideologies
authoritarian.
It's racist.
It's,
um,
and,
and they engage in very scary vicious
behaviors.
Yeah.
So absolutely.
I will coast side all of that.
Just for the record,
of course,
this is a repugnant ideology and these
people are racist and all those things.
So I'm less concerned about that because
I do believe it's a small sliver that
doesn't have real institutional power.
Now maybe it's going to gain some.
And I think there's evidence that at
least in eastern Europe that some of
these ideas,
partly as a pushback to the immigration
immigration problems that maybe it is
gaining some power.
Um,
but are you concerned that it has a
bigger institutional power?
Because I think the stuff that we're
often talking about is because we're
worried about institutional power and
structural power,
not just that they were mean and bad
people out there,
which yes,
there are bad people out there and there
will always be mean and bad people out
there.
Yeah.
Because my background is so recently in
academia,
I focus a lot on universities and the
ideologies that are popular within the
university.
So that makes me focus on left wing
ideology such as critical theory,
poststructuralism and Marxism.
Um,
if I was in a different context,
I might focus more on right wing
ideologies and the effect that they have
on institutions and I'm sure.
So you're given a little nod to the
postmodern.
Is there because you're showing that
your own bias is a little part of how
you look at things?
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
I'm sure if I was closer to institutions
that have more of a right wing
ideological influence,
our would be criticizing that more,
criticizing those influences more.
I'm being Australian is a in Australia,
out out conservative or right wing
ideologies are quite different to
America.
So you probably already know this,
but we have universal healthcare,
we have gun control,
we have a welfare state.
So if I lived in a country where we
didn't have those things,
I would probably be advocating for them.
Um,
but you know,
a lot of this is context specific and
you criticize what you know.
So a part of the reason why I criticize
the,
um,
what Jordan Peterson calls,
postmodern near Marxism is because I've
experienced it,
I see it all the time in Aca,
in academia,
academic settings,
and,
um,
I worry about the impact that,
that ideology is having on media,
the law,
um,
and just the broader culture.
Yeah.
Are you hopeful that some of the good
ideas that we've talked about here are
going to win out?
That that seems to be one of the biggest
questions I get at public events now.
Like I think there is a sense that we've
woken up a certain amount of people,
you know,
this Peterson towards selling out every
theater.
Thousands and thousands of people
literally all over the world will be in
February,
uh,
in Australia in February.
But I think there's still a concern of
like how much worse before it gets
better.
Yeah.
And that's a question people,
me as well,
and I the.
I mean I don't have an oracle,
I can't see the future.
And all I can say is that I'm doing my
very best to counter these bad ideas and
that it's,
it's actually anybody who's concerned.
I mean they have some responsibility and
I think everybody should think about
sharing the risk.
So,
you know,
Charlie truly
right?
Yeah.
You know,
when Charlie Hebdo happened and the
mainstream media in Europe and the UK
and America,
I think didn't want to publish that
cartoon of Muhammad,
which got those men and women killed.
Douglas Murray came out and said,
do it.
Share the risk.
That's when I came aware of one of his
best moments is incredible.
It's on youtube.
Yeah.
That was a,
uh,
something that impacted me a lot as
well.
And you know,
anyone who's concerned about the way our
culture,
broader western culture is headed,
needs to think deeply about how they can
make a little bit of difference by
sharing the risk.
Just speaking honestly,
in conversations with friends speaking
honestly and openly in the workplace,
normalizing conversations and um,
yeah,
just,
just taking on a little bit of risk,
what does that tell you about the slide
that has occurred in the West?
Is this just a,
is it an infection of success or
something that we could be so successful
that even taking a little risk seems
awful to people.
He,
he,
he runs a very conformist and most
people a cow.
It's unfortunately,
um,
and a lot of what we're talking about,
these bad ideas that are being promoted.
I only promoted by a tiny,
tiny minority of people,
but they're very noisy,
loud and aggressive.
And the problem is simply the silent
majority not being feeling too
intimidated to sort of push back.
And if we can encourage those who are in
the silent majority to push back against
it,
logs on both sides,
both the hard right and the hard left.
Um,
I think,
oh,
create a much healthier civil society,
but it's about empowering the moderates
to speak freely,
speak openly and,
and,
and not feel afraid,
like ashamed of the moderate views.
Right?
They've also turned the words like
civility and moderation or thought of as
bad.
Now you're a fence sitter.
You don't want to murder half the people
you know,
you're not ost from avengers,
right?
Yeah.
I mean those people,
that people who are gay,
that civility is,
is a bad thing.
And um,
we see a lot of this now by the way,
that civility is a bad thing.
A lot of pieces about.
Well,
I would argue that some unrepresentative
of the broader population,
I know that media and certain parts of
media and universities have been
captured by cultists in a way and they
have these crazy ideas.
But I would be careful about
generalizing those ideas to the broader
population because I think most normal
people are pretty chill.
I mean,
I haven't.
It's been not enough time in your
country to,
to know.
No,
I,
I think you are right.
I mean,
I'm out there going across the country
realizing that there are so many just
decent people that hysterics and the way
that I said earlier about how social
media has leaked into reality or
something.
It's making everyone feel crazy.
But I'm meeting these incredible people
all over the country.
They just want to live and let live and
yeah,
maybe I don't know your feelings on
abortion for example.
Maybe we agree.
Maybe we don't.
It just seems that actually seems
irrelevant at the moment.
Yeah.
That,
that sort of says something we touched
on briefly right before we started that
politics.
I was saying how I'm not that interested
in politics per se at the moment,
even though this is all framed within a
political lens that I'm much more
interested in culture.
Is that how you feel about this and was
that always how you felt about this or
it has something shifted?
Definitely.
I've never been particularly interested
in partisan politics,
but I think that politics is downstream
of culture.
So the ideas that are popular within a
culture then get reflected in your
politics.
So if you want politics to be a certain
way and to be a bit healthier and less
dysfunctional,
you want to impact the culture first
because culture is bigger than politics.
Yeah.
Is there a danger that we're just in
this like locked culture war now so that
our politics can never get better?
Like we sort of have this affair
authoritarian leftism and now we've got
trump.
These are,
these are the cultural fights that we're
having now.
There's a couple of us in this spot.
Right?
But like that,
it's all politics is going to come from
those two things at the moment.
The politics sort of is almost
irreparably damaged.
Yeah.
Look,
I don't know what the future holds for
the United States.
From an outsider looking in it,
it does look quite scary that the level
of tribalism that's,
that seems a parent.
Just the amount of hate and distrust
that each side has for the other.
It's quite scary.
Um,
I just hope that if the worst happens to
the United States,
we will always have.
We will have outposts where western
civilization survives and thrives.
New Zealand,
Australia.
Basically going back to what I said at
the beginning,
it's good to be surrounded by water will
be,
we will be an outpost and will kill the
extra moving your house.
We're going to keep you that much.
A couple of feet work.
Yeah.
A lot of people are going to New Zealand
and buying houses there in case the
worst happens.
Oh God,
I don't want to end on this terrible.
Wait,
we've got to bring this back,
but all right,
so there's concern about that.
Of course,
like right,
if you want to go down that rabbit hole,
you could look at all of these ideas
that I truly think are the ideas that
could unravel western society and free
thought and all of those things.
That's why I talk about them so much,
but there is a counter and that's what
we got to keep doing,
so bring it,
bring it,
bring it home on a positive note please.
Before people start buying real estate
in New Zealand or you were just trying
to help them market in Australia there.
No,
we don't need any help in the housing
market.
We.
I'm optimistic because I see the amount,
the positive reception that I get
through quizlet,
our audience grows every month.
I'm more and more people are
contributing to our website,
feeling brave enough to write their
thoughts down and send it through,
and the thing is every individual has
the power to change the world of ideas.
If you've got an idea and you can
articulate it and write it down and send
it in or articulated it in in some other
fashion,
you do have the power to transform and
impact this,
this culture,
and to make a huge difference.
So that's,
that's incredible.
And that makes me feel happy and
optimistic.
All right.
That is how we can add.
We can end it on the seasteading.
We're going to water world kind of thing
for more on Claire's work.
Check out [inaudible] dot com and they
are also on Patriot.